les vaccins sont au coeur des stratégies
de lutte contre la corée 19 mai d'autres
traitements pharmacologiques ont aussi
un rôle essentiel à jouer c'est très
important de trouver des nouveaux
médicaments qui pourraient réduire les
risques d'hospitalisation ou aider les
patients déjà atteints par la maladie à
s'en remettre
mais fabriquer un nouveau médicament
partir de zéro c'est quelque chose qui
prend énormément de temps et dans
l'urgence de la pandémie
certains chercheurs ont opté pour une
autre stratégie utiliser des médicaments
qui sont déjà employés dans le
traitement d'autres maladies
mais même avec des molécules qu'on
connaît déjà faire de la recherche
sérieuse c'est très difficile et si
certains de ces médicaments ont connu
des succès on a aussi vu beaucoup de
faux pas pourquoi utiliser les
médicaments déjà commercialisés pour
traiter la coved 19
plusieurs chercheurs croient que parmi
les milliers de molécules déjà
commercialisés
certaines pourraient avoir des effets
inattendus contre la coved 19 comme
réduire les symptômes les plus graves ou
interférer avec le fonctionnement du
virus depuis le début de la pandémie des
centaines d'études ont été publiées sur
ces médicaments prometteurs qui pourrait
s'il fonctionne à être disponible très
rapidement parce qu'on connaît ces
molécules et les effets secondaires qui
viennent avec des études sérieuses et
bien fait pourrait donc rapidement nous
donner des nouvelles thérapies souvent
plus abordable et ce serait crucial dans
la situation actuelle
pourquoi autant de recherche si les
médicaments sont déjà connus c'est pas
parce qu'un médicament semble avoir des
effets prometteurs en laboratoire qu'on
peut immédiatement utilisant clinique
il faut évaluer son effet chez des
patients atteints de kobe 19 pour voir
si son efficacité contre le virus est
réel rendre disponible médicaments avant
d'avoir confirmé son efficacité sa peu
accaparé des ressources qui auraient été
mieux utilisés sur un médicament
réellement prometteurs où ça pour
exposer des patients à des effets
secondaires qui pourrait leur nuire
c'est ce qui est arrivé avec l'hydro xi
chloroquine qui a été largement
publicisé l'an dernier malgré des études
initiales malmené il y aura fallu
beaucoup de temps et d'efforts pour
montrer que finalement les effets de ce
médicament contre la kfw de 19
ce n'était pas réel et ça c'est un
scénario qu'on voulait éviter de répéter
comment un médicament peut s'attaquer au
virus de la coved 19
il n'existe pas de médicament capable de
détruire un virus de la même manière
qu'un antibiotique peut détruire une
bactérie mais il existe des molécules
qui peuvent interférer avec les
mécanismes que le virus utilise pour
prendre contrôle de nos cellules où se
multiplier on appelle ces molécules les
antiviraux une de celles que le plus
attiré l'attention début de la pandémie
s'appelle le remdh et sévir soucier de
molécules que été initialement conçus
pour combattre le virus ebola
mais au début de la pandémie on s'est
rendu compte que je médicament peut
aussi réduire la durée des
hospitalisations
chez les patients atteints de kobe 19
ans en a fait un des premiers
médicaments être approuvée dans le
traitement de cette maladie
mais en octobre dernier une très grosse
étude de lohan s hormis cet effet lent
question en dehors du remdh et suivirent
d'autres antiviraux sont présentement à
l'étude
et on attend les résultats de ces études
prochainement y at il des médicaments
qui réduisent les symptômes chez les
patients hospitalisés
une des complications les plus graves de
la coved 19 implique des réactions
immunitaires incontrôlée ou
l'inflammation venir faire des dégâts
partout à travers le corps surtout au
niveau des poumons
c'est pour ça qu'on s'intéresse aux anti
inflammatoires des médicaments qui vont
réduire ces réactions démesurées chez
des patients déjà hospitalisés 1 les
anti inflammatoires qui intéresse le
plus est la dexaméthasone une molécule
qu'on connaît depuis les années 50 et
qu'on utilise notamment pour le
traitement de l'arthrite
plus récemment une étude canadienne a
montré qu'un autre anti inflammatoire la
colchicine un vieux médicament qu'on
utilise pour le traitement de la goutte
pouvait réduire les hospitalisations
chez les personnes à risque
mais c'était une nécessité encore
confirmation ce qui est clair c'est
qu'il n'existe pas de médicament miracle
contre la kfw 19 son médecin traitant de
combiner les molécules qui sont à sa
disposition pour offrir les meilleures
chances de survie à ses patients
n'hésitez pas à nous envoyer vos
questions à l'adresse que vous voyez à
l'écran
et nous on va y répondre le plus
rapidement possible